[Musique]
bonjour et bon voyage au cap et je crois
qu'il est question aujourd'hui
d'omelette norvégienne norvégienne oui
c'est bien ça c'est ça tu songes est
souple et dans laquelle on met de la
glace on a mis de la glace en inspecter
giraud l'ombre sont son appellation
nordiques mais néanmois je crois que son
origine est tout autre non oui on
prétend que c'est un physicien enfin
c'est tout à fait tout ce que vous savez
comment sont les 800 jours les origines
des plats mais là on peut attendre c'est
un physicien américain qui s'appelait
renfort qui a résumé benjamin renfort
qui avait d'ailleurs fait des études sur
la marmite norvégienne et qui s'est
aperçu que lorsque l'on isolé de la
glace on pourrait très bien la mettre
dans un four puisque cette isolation la
protéger de la chaleur alors et là il a
trouvé la retrouver ce principe il
pensait que c'était l'ère l'air
seulement suffisent et à isoler la glace
et que par conséquent on pouvait
impunément
si je puisse employer ce mot mettre de
la glace sans infos sans pour autant
qu'elles fondent
eh bien voyez vos nous allons composer
ici ce que l'on appelle en anglais un
appareil à anglet souffler alors on va
incorporer du sucre dans des jaunes
quelqu'un dit aussi alors là elle se
sent gênée pour des lignes nous donnons
tout à l'heure des quantités mais là je
les fais un petit peu comme ça au petit
bonheur la chance
il y avait trois étangs il y avait eu
droit à deux trois jaunes d'oeuf et puis
du sucre se sucrent je pense qu'il y en
a environ 200 membres
en réalité je vais boire je vais voir si
jamais assez mais je vous dirai tout à
l'heure les proportions pour vous
pourrez parce que je suis déjà dans mon
travail et qu'on pense davantage alors
fsu croyez-vous que de travail alors là
je vais travailler jusqu'à ce que ça
devient le plan on appelle ça faire
blanchir l'appareil oui cela vous nous
l'avez déjà
10 plusieurs points juridiques et bien
voyez-vous chaque fois que dans des
recettes même différente très
différentes
on retrouve le même processus il faut se
livrer pour même tu auras c'est-à-dire
blanche que ce soit extrêmement lisse ou
15 ans en plus
ces signaux envoyés si fastidieux que ce
soit je suis obligé d'en passer par là
pour que on s'aperçoit bien je sais
qu'il faut faire ça s'agite un peu tout
vous pouvez y compris peut-être
l'enlever au rouge de force
vous leur demanderez en temps utile et
bien catherine ci voulait me donner la
bouteille de liqueur et l'échappement
dire est ce que c'est mais c'est
sûrement rien omettre un tout petit peu
fier de son choix
la liqueur de son choix je préconise
beaucoup l'emploi de liqueur à base
d'orange landes pas mal de ses
préparations là pour que cette unité
ration gilles va bien au feu furent à
soan yz aussi l'anis l'anisette vont
aussi assez bien mais l'opération c'est
ma passion est tout à fait libre oui
absolument
je trouve que ce sont les liqueur à base
d'herbes qui ceux qui se comportent le
moins bien au feu alors laquelle
consistance cela peut-il prêt ou une
crème
quinze jours serait de la cuisine pour
les émissions tout seul viti pour nous
téléspectateurs
bon et bien là catherine je m'occupais
des plans tout de suite et des blancs
voyez vous je vais en montée tout petit
peu plus qu'il n'est nécessaire
c'est tout ceci c'est pour la
démonstration ce qui fait que c'est une
des raisons pour lesquelles je ne vous
donnerai pas proportions tout à l'heure
c'est qu'en réalité il ya une petite
différence entre ce que je fais ici et
la façon de le faire chez soi en ce sens
qu'ici je suis quelquefois un peu
prodigue en quelque sorte pour que ce
soit plus spectaculaire voilà autrement
dit vous ne prenez pas les trois blancs
de vous avez laissé tout à leur nom je
pense à 8 environ mais en réalité est ce
qu on doit se servir des trois blancs 2
vous avez séparer tout à l'air bien sûr
on ajouter d'autres y en a ajouté deux
fautes en joyaux je sors un tout petit
peu les blancs toujours
et puis je vais remonter ces instruments
cas dans les preneurs de son ah oui ça
alors là aussi nous allons passer un
petit moment asti dieu c'est à dire le
moment de monter les blancs j'ai
peut-être pourrais-je de 30 par l'éclat
la passion pleinement aujourd'hui et où
au début ils vous accueillent au début
on les ports dans le coup et doucement
dans le coup et sans d'autres la
casserole sans son bac pour un bol avec
un crochet par colombo la block party et
vous allez souffle opérant des galets à
l'intérieur de ces plans les plus vite
non absolument à bien pas de geste
inutile
soyons rationnels tu peu mal placé là
lorsque j'ai moi même lorsque je fais
une lettre au régime c'est moi car je
ferai peut-être
j'aimerais que vous oubliez tout sourire
jane il ressort de soumissionner
toujours à ses montées je vais pouvoir
les prendre le plus violemment alors
[Musique]
la pression monte et trois experts
vous allez voir en fait ça
[Musique]
si vous recevez du blanc d'oeuf ou les
laisser sécher et andreu 177 seulement
des claques merci ni virement
alors oui je redonne un petit foot pour
que les gens ne soient bien les blancs
alors comme ceux ci comme étant le
premier foyer carrément décidé de rien
rémois le but de tenir très important
fort bien mais cela je vais le faire
demeurait à l'armé blanche
vous avez ça ça ne fait pas tomber
absolument rien alors ici je vais sucré
voyez vous comme ça légèrement ce n'est
pas grave non plus et je vais me lancer
enfin pour tenue mais le plus mauvais
disque non ce n'est pas un débat mais
justifié pourquoi pas la morale c'est ça
ma fille moi c'est ça oui ça y est eh
bien bon et bien sûr d'être dans le
silence tout d'un coup là alors je
prends une poche
voyez où ça enfonce la poche dans la
douille comme ceci pour éviter que ce
que je mets dans la proche du nôtre et
bien ne coule ou je m'excuse je suis un
véritable sens m c'est du sport l'a
alors ici jeu mais confondant meringue
dans la poche
j'aurais pu aussi mince relate plus tôt
l'appareil à malley souffle est plutôt
pas mal d'ailleurs génère aucune raison
spéciale
l'un ou l'autre ne passe pas tous les
deux ça n'a pas le même investissement
si si si alors ce que je voulais vous
dire justement c'est ce que l'on peut
faire une omelette norvégienne avec deux
la hongrie commande ou bien avec
l'appareil et anglet comme on veut
peut-être un peu plus oui c'est tout de
même meilleur à mon avis bon alors ici
je vais mettre cette poche de côté une
seconde et je vais prendre le plat que
voilà merci c'est le plan général dans
lequel vous présenter le plat fini si je
ne sais ça alors voici ici deux plats
chinois
alors attendez je vais la coupe et on la
verra très bien ne faudrait leur est
coupée en morceaux
voilà aujourd'hui on sait la faire oui
en tout cas j'ai dit comment il fallait
la faire et si on n'a pas des noises se
lire une catastrophe on peut très bien
s'en passer
on peut très bien mettre des biscuits à
la cuillère ou des biscuits quelconque
ce que l'on veut ce tout c'est d'isoler
la glace avec quelque chose alors nous
pouvons la colère c'est que génoise
également au plus de précaution mais là
aussi non c'est un petit peu de crème
pâtissière
mais on pourrait la coller avec de
l'appareil ou avec delà de la meringue
ça n'a aucune espèce d'importance à ça
c'est important
c'est pour qu'elle soit stable alors et
si voyez vous
je m'en vais inciser la meurin la part
la génoise voix ne porte pour pouvoir
introduire bien comme il faut
la glace dedans alors là c'est quand
même j'arrose un tout petit peu avec un
public a été bien je vais gérer
catherine je vais être prêt c'est bien
je vais faire immédiatement
cette omelette c'est à dire je vais
aller chercher pourquoi sais pas comment
s'est il inquiété
je vais chercher la glace faire il faut
de la glace sous lens tout à fait au
delà si joliment classique comme celle
que vous avez apprise à faire ou bien
comme celles qu'on peut acheter
comme c'est le cas chez le pâtissier
alors là il y en a un lit que je vais
prendre ce qui m'est nécessaire
alors je vais vous ferez comme ceci vaut
la chandelle
oui voyez vous allez moelleuse oui là et
encore ici comme je lui ai dit où je
vais tout mettre la voyez vous revient
maintenant qu'ils nous voient pas
pourquoi catherine tout cela va nous
mener un papa je n'ai pas confiance
maintenant voyez vous versez la pelouse
vers ce l'appareil à anglet soufflé sur
le tout en ayant soin de le répartir
tout recouvrir de tout recouvrir de bien
répartir ordonné cet appareil oui mais
c'est ce qui fonde la alors une stature
et avec cette statue je m'en avait
unifié voyez la toto cet appareil
gaspillage la nouvelle est ce que vous
dites pas de mollesse bien entendu mais
le temps me reste cinq minutes 5 6
minutes c'est donc parfait voilà
mais qu'est ce que vous allez en faire
maintenant c'est fini
eh bien je vais le mettre au fond faire
cuire une cuisse alors comment un four
chaud chaud mais pas trop chaud là eh
bien je vais le décor élabore avec la
meringue rôle est mis à chauffer il ya
quelques minutes
alors je voudrais que ce soit propre ici
et je voudrais voyons je crois que je
devrais être dans un bon angle
c'est uniquement pour la décoration
encore une fois il est pas absolument
indispensable en fait du fait qu'on a
montrées blanc on en a à sa disposition
ce sera exactement quand on peut faire
ce petit jeu petit des scores noblement
terre là et bien maintenant nous allons
aller au four alors le four je vais le
mettre sur os et je m'ennuie c'est de le
alors c'était jusqu'à présent un trophée
dessous et maintenant je chauffe dessus
autrement dit puisque vous nous avez dit
qu'il vous restait le temps de terminer
cette baisse des prix de 5 à 6 minutes
de cuisson non 80,6 suis logique c'est
bien maintenant vous allez nous rappelez
peut-être je vais revenir d'abord
préparer un plat pourquoi on voit si sur
lequel je vais mettre de la glace parce
que maintenant je risque ainsi de
continuer à laisser mon nom ma lettre
comme ceci je risquais que tout de même
le plat de choc trop et à ce moment-là
il risquerait de faire fondre tout de
même la glace par capillarité ou commun
alors maintenant je vais le sortir leur
tournée et une fois retourné de le poser
sur ce plat qui a été doublé avec de la
vie
eo voyons alors je reviens j'ai déjà oui
alors vous allez voir il ya déjà pris de
la couleur
alors je viens avec ce plat regardez
bien les gens pensent qu'un danger
pisode 13 heures ça voyez vous il est
déjà coloré un tout petit peu elle est
un petit peu coloré de suivre les yeux
alors je mets de la glace je tourne le
plat et je remets sur la glace pilée
cette fois ci et cette grâce à des
formules médiator ça n'a aucune
importance pas à ces rites cependant
pour protéger le gâteau c'est de la
véritable physique
alors oui voyez vous alors si vous
voulez maintenant catherine pendant que
ça finit de cuir nous pourrions préparer
une aussi à pithiviers aussi deux nous
allons récapituler mais je cherche mais
nécessaire et a pris parce que je me
d'autre que tout à l'heure de l'avenir
mais comment ça se passe à l'intérieur
je vais aller voir et bien voilà nous
allons avec récupérer un tout petit peu
notre recette
si vous voulez pour quatre personnes
nous allons dire qu un demi litre de
glace est nécessaire en 2008 où un tout
petit peu plus ensuite trois journées
n'est ce pas 250 grammes faibles
c'est-à-dire de 200 et 250 tout ce que
les trois ou quatre jours sinon je vous
dis à 3 et tous ceux que ces trois
jeunes pourront prendre de sucre c'est
d'ailleurs si vous voyez que c'est trop
mou il ya que je dois faire c'est
ajouter beaucoup de sucre peu importe si
si si ou quand même il y aurait 250
grammes et ça serait pas assez il
faudrait en ajouter
ça c'est très important alors ici je
vais glacé avec je voudrais expliquer
pourquoi que vous disais je descends je
vous disais qu'il fallait trois jours
250 grammes une 2 millions demi litre de
crème de crème glacée et puis il faut
battre le double demain c'est à dire il
faudra environ au moins six blancs si on
veut faire ça sans décor sans rien
simplement l'omelette et si on veut
faire un décor il faut ajouter un ou
deux ça sent bon mais ça doit sentir
même trop fort 8 c'est ce que je vois
alors où ici n'est ce pas je vais glace
et maintenant c'est à dire que les
saupoudrer avec du sucre glace c'est une
opération très utile et très utile très
utile décoratives c'est entendu mais
très utile et je m'en vais couper la
chaleur qui sera suffisant eh bien vous
le voyez peut-être la glace n'est pas
pour du beurre puisque nous allons venir
alors maintenant quelques secondes ça va
être fini alors je reprends on met on
mais c'est en fait c'est blanc d'oeuf
très très fort c'est à dire on les fout
est très ferme plus exactement et on les
mélange si on veut faire un décor on en
garde un petit peu que l'on mélange avec
du sucre ça fait un petit peu demeurant
que l'on met en vie dans une poche avec
laquelle on fait un petit décor
si on ne veut pas on peut très bien s'en
passer une fois que cet appareil est
prêt mélangez il faut le ménager en
coupant ce que vous avez vu comment il
faut faire on le met sur l'anglais theo
mais celle ci au four alors il faut
quelques minutes de cuisson si je vais
parler la finance nommé alors la génoise
doit être là fort isolé mais c'est trop
quand même très bon à manger par
conséquent elle doit être fraîche il
doit être un peu imbibés biblique
alors ceci étant fait on le met au four
s'est très vite plié mais pas trop vite
il ne faut pas s'imaginer qu'il suffit
de la faire colorer
parce que si il suffisait de faire
coller il faut la faire que il faut
connaître sa carrière en ce moment bien
que vous ayez fermer votre four elle est
en train de cuire
alors je voudrais justement insisté un
peu là dessus sur le fait que l'omelette
doit être cuite avant d'être derrière on
doit la surveiller si j'ai ma vie ici on
fait comme vous voulez bien je vais la
sorte que tout de suite après je me
permettrai dire vraiment
nantes qu'il faudrait fait pour que vous
ayez froid parce qu'une hamlet dans les
gènes vous a plutôt donné chaud c'est un
vrai travail voilà alors voici
l'omelette norvégienne
elle est fin prête qu'est-ce un peu 3,6
alors voyez vous de régulation
évidemment fondu en grande partie mais
pas entièrement quand même foyer bon
petit bout de jungle à caraméliser
alors maintenant si vous voulez
catherine nous pouvons l'ouvrir de façon
à bien voir ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur et bien attendu
alors voilà la glace et vos potes kit
intacte bien glacé ils l'ont menacée
cuite puisque voyez comme elle vient
bien et puis au fond si l'on veut dire
on ne peut pas qu'un petit noir que
voilà et bien catherine je crois que la
démonstration les pros banques cfb
m'exprimer ainsi
et voilà la recette de l'emblème
norvégien alors si jamais eu l'intention
de garder ça pour moi
[Musique]
nous avons un jour montrer qu'ils
mangeaient ses plats alors je vais le
voir tous ces parfaits et coupé deux
places
voilà c'est un homme extraordinaire en
effet de penser qu'en isolant ses
principes de la marmite la marée
norvégien marmite norvégienne tout ça
monsieur renfort qui est tous à table de
18 oui on verra ses parents ont peur
renfort et 10 10 10 un petit peu avant
18 ans et la fin du xviiie siècle et
bien j'ai bien dans cette voie là mais
c'est que vous entrez 4
je vous assure que cela peut être très
bon
c'est chaud et froid l'a signalé
chaud-froid mais qui sont toujours
croire que le plat qui s'appelle un
chaud froid est toujours froid j'ai bien
montrer que cela était réel
je ne vous dis pas si je vais manger ou
pas en tout cas merci vraiment de son
excellente recette vous donc elle n'est
pas très difficile à réaliser
or vaka très bon ça
[Musique]